we've been covering the topic of Donald
Trump's involvement with Russia for a
long time I don't think I have to rehash
the entire thing for you but we've heard
countless denials from Donald Trump
about connections to Russia we have
heard denials from Donald Trump about
discussing deals with Russia in any
serious manner he went there for his
beauty pageant and that's really about
it that Moscow Trump tower project years
ago wasn't serious and Donald Trump was
barely involved in it whatsoever that's
the storyline that we've heard from
Donald Trump but it continues to get
worse and worse and more and more
apparent lying is being exposed and we
now have two previously unreported data
points we can call them that contradict
Donald Trump's claims first we have a
video that has been released which
claims to be of Donald Trump and I think
there's no question that it is Donald
Trump it claims to be a meeting in
Russia with the deputy mayor of Moscow
Vladimir reson in 1995 about a building
project and again this was allegedly in
1995 if that's true this is a previously
unreported attempt to make a deal to do
business with Russia and it is one of
the many that now are on the list that
supposedly didn't exist that's number
one and the the accuracy of the
description of that video is being from
1995 in Moscow is being investigated but
that certainly does appear to be Donald
Trump there and the language track by
the way if you listen to it is Russian
there's also additional new claims
published in Newsweek yesterday that
Donald Trump was in talks with Russians
to build an underground mall in Moscow
in the 1990s it would have been close to
the state duma which is the lower house
of Russia's Federal Assembly so of
course that's not a crime but let's go
back to the story that we've been told
and we're going to talk about this later
today with Molly McHugh Trump claims
nothing with Russia no deals
barely been there doesn't deal with
Russians nothing nothing nothing
and then of course we learned the
reality he went in 1987 a report says he
was looking at an
Brown mall in the 90s he's on video
purportedly in 1995 looking at another
project he worked on the Trump Tower
Moscow Deal way more than he admitted
there were plans for the building which
were now released and that was all
happening during the 2016 presidential
campaign so we have a serial liar about
this specific issue we're not hearing
Trump deny that he's done business in
Chile and then we find out here's five
instances of Trump trying to do business
in Chile it's not happening with
Madagascar it's not happening with any
other country it's happening with Russia
and Trump's denials have been numerous
Trump said in July of 2016 I have
nothing to do with Russia I'm all over
the world but we're not involved in
Russia well he was involved at the time
he was investigating at the time
Trump Tower Moscow plans schematics
designs a builder had been identified in
October of 2016 during the second
presidential debate Hillary said
Russia's trying to help elect Trump and
Trump said that it's ridiculous and that
he knows nothing about Russia and
doesn't deal there there are six eight
ten twelve of these denials even early
on and they were all lies and every time
that a new story comes out its
downplayed well okay fine there was
something but these were low-level
conversations it wasn't serious it
wasn't secrets
it wasn't Trump himself who was involved
and every single time we find out that
that wasn't the truth we found out it
wasn't the truth with Moscow Trump Tower
we found out that it wasn't the truth
because here's a video allegedly of a
meeting that was never reported never
disclosed remember when lying mattered
remember when Trump called for the end
to the investigation into his wrongdoing
during a State of the Union speech two
nights ago we now have two more reasons
why we can't let the investigations be
short-circuited by Trump because we are
only at the tip of the iceberg as to
what has gone on and later on in the
program Molly McHugh is going to talk to
us about it in a lot of depth give me
your take on this video I
on Twitter at D Pakman and the show is
on Twitter at David Pakman show today's
program is sponsored in part by Blink
accom slash Pakman if you've not already
heard about blink Asst it's amazing it's
an app for your phone tablet or web
browser and what they do is they take
nonfiction books popular nonfiction
critically acclaimed nonfiction they
condense the book into a 15 minute audio
book you get all the most important
information and insights from each book
but you can soak up the entire essence
of the book in one sitting I've listened
to a ton of books on blinkin recent one
is a Robert Rice's new book the common
good
also bunk by Kevin Young useful in
preparing me for the pseudo-science
miniseries that we're producing and if
you are a david pakman show viewer or
listener you can get a seven day free
trial by going to blink accom slash
Pakman if you're watching on youtube use
the link in the video description
after the free trial if you like it you
can get the full access to thousands of
condensed audiobooks for about five
bucks a month that's be li NK is t.com
/pa ke ma n